ladies and gentlemen good evening and
welcome to Central Connecticut State
University my name is John Doyle I have
the pleasure of serving as a member of
the board of trustees for the
Connecticut State University system and
I bring you the greetings from our board
chair Larry McHugh and our Chancellor
dr. David Carter I'd like to begin by
reading you a brief statement from CCSU
professor Norton Mezvinsky Norton as
many of you know his mat were showers
mentor friend and now colleague in CCS
use history department
Norton writes since I have a speaking
engagement in Arizona I unfortunately
cannot attend mat wash hours book talk I
have therefore asked John Doyle to read
a few words of mine on this occasion
matt has distinguished himself as an
excellent historian by writing a superb
book published by a first-rate
University Press that presents new
insights about Andrew Jackson and
martial law Matt in his book are
receiving the national coverage and
praise they deserve as a friend and
colleague I am happy for him as a former
teacher of his when he was an
undergraduate at CCS you I am proud
beyond words and what he has
accomplished there is no doubt in my
mind that Matt was a young man but
nonetheless and already mature and
productive scholar will contribute to
the in the future with even more
published books and articles all of us
at CCS you should and I am sure we do
admire Matt for what he has accomplished
he symbolizes the highest ideals of
Central he received his undergraduate
education here and then went on to
graduate school and ultimately earning
his PhD he subsequently returned as a
faculty member of the C CSU history
department and has since that time
contributed significantly as a scholar
as a teacher and as editor of the
journal Connecticut history and is an
involved in campus affairs faculty
member Matt were showers should be held
up as a model of a successful CCSU
person he deserves to be honored that's
the end of norton sri marks and all I
can say Matt is I enthusiastically agree
with dr. Mezvinsky and I'm now delighted
to introduce our speaker for the evening
dr. Matt warschauer
thank you very much John and I'd like to
begin by thanking everybody for coming
this evening as as people came in and I
got an opportunity to greet them it was
people who I knew well who I was
greeting friends former students
colleagues and I do appreciate you
coming this evening so let's talk about
the United States Constitution the
Constitution which was written in 1787
and ratified in 1789 created the system
of government that we have today it
created a system in checks and balances
when that Constitution was created there
was when it was first written prior to
its ratification
there were great concerns on the part of
many that it created a government that
was too powerful coming out of the
American Revolution with the power of
Parliament the power of ammon our kacal
of a monarchy the King George many were
concerned that the government would
trample the liberties of the people
hence we all have learned the ideas of
checks and balances it's something that
we learn in grade school and into high
school the idea is that we would create
a system of government that would give
our legislators and our leaders enough
power in order to get things done but
not so much power that they would
trample on the individual rights of the
people one of the things that they did
in order to get the Constitution
ratified was to create the first ten
amendments what we know as the Bill of
Rights those bill of rights are touted
by many and we know them the first
freedom of speech freedom of religion
freedom of the press the right to bear
arms and the list goes on throughout the
first ten amendments well the ten
amendments aren't the only things that
safeguard our liberties embedded within
the Constitution itself is the right of
habeas corpus
essentially what habeas corpus is is it
allows any person who is arrested to
petition through an attorney to a judge
and if you are arrested and you're being
held in a dozen weathered matter whether
it's by the military whether it's by the
local police you can go to a judge have
a lawyer go to a judge for you and the
judge can issue a writ of habeas corpus
which literally from the latin
translates to
the body for Thor or let the body appear
and the idea is to bring you from your
cell before a judge to make sure that
you are being held legally to make sure
that the government or the you know the
holding authorities aren't merely
placing you in jail and sitting on you
and not allowing you to have your
Liberty and so the writ of habeas corpus
is something that actually comes from
English law and as American law much of
American law is based on English law it
is one of the the principal acts that
came from England and was embedded
within our own Constitution
well habeas corpus of late has been
under some degree of assault for good or
bad and we'll talk a little bit about
that as we go along but just recently in
regards to habeas corpus there's a wide
variety of things that have occurred on
January 17 2007 for example the Attorney
General of the United States
Albert Gonzaga Hollis made a statement
before the Senate Judiciary Committee in
which he said quote the Constitution
doesn't say every individual in the
United States or every citizen is hereby
granted or assured the right of habeas
corpus
well that would go against what most
historians what most constitutional
scholars what most history has said
about the Constitution and about the
writ of habeas corpus or the right of
habeas corpus habeas corpus is also
often linked directly with the idea of
martial law that the suspension of
habeas corpus allows essentially martial
law the idea of the military controlling
the domestic police force or the
military controlling civilian operations
in addition to alberto gonzalez's
comments there are other things that
have happened in the last month for
example a recent New York Times
editorial on February 19 2007 entitled
making martial law easier was published
what this editorial discussed was a
recent October defense bill that was
pushed through the Congress and a rider
to that bill essentially made it easier
for the President to establish martial
martial law to allow martial law to be
used as a domestic
in addition to this we have the military
commissions Act of 2006 which was a
direct response to the recent Supreme
Court ruling in Hamden versus Rumsfeld
and what the military commissions act
essentially does is it at Achatz
habeas corpus for any suspected
terrorist or any enemy combatant so they
can essentially be arrested and this is
one of the problems with what has been
happening in Guantanamo Bay as they can
essentially somebody can be arrested and
held indefinitely never appear before a
court in addition to this we have our
own in the state of Connecticut senator
Christopher Dodd who is now running for
president just recently like in the last
week just put out an email entitled
restoring the Constitution Act of 2007
and one of his primary concerns is
resurrecting or safeguarding the writ of
habeas corpus so in order to understand
the importance of habeas corpus today we
have to kind of take a step back and
look at where habeas corpus has been in
the past and how it has been related to
martial law so what I'm going to be
speaking to United tonight about is
about Andrew Jackson's suspension of
habeas the writ of habeas right of
habeas corpus and his imposition of
martial law in New Orleans in 1814 1815
this was the very first time that habeas
corpus was ever suspended it was the
first time that martial law was ever
imposed in the United States and we can
talk a little bit as we would go along
about whether that has lessons for the
future but it certainly had a precedent
for the future
Jackson's suspension of habeas corpus
however was not the very first time that
habeas corpus had been attempted to be
suspended the first time occurred in
1806 1807 President Thomas Jefferson
responding to the burr conspiracy and
this was his own former vice president
Aaron Burr had the two of them had had a
falling-out burr wasn't thrilled with
the way that Jefferson was handling the
government and he had taken a trip in
the West and he got the idea that
perhaps it would be a good idea to
separate the newly aquired southward
Western
portion of the united states primarily
new orleans from the rest of the country
and he got involved in this scheme and
news of it got out and Jefferson sent
agents out into the West to find out
what Weber was doing and he when the
agents returned to Jefferson and told
him what was going on Jefferson went to
the legislature and requested that they
suspend the writ of habeas corpus now
specifically in the Constitution it
allows suspension of the writ of habeas
corpus article 9 section 2 states the
privilege of the writ of habeas corpus
shall not be suspended unless when in
cases of rebellion or invasion the
public safety may require it now in
terms of historical precedent about the
development the overall development of
emergency powers we can look to a
variety of things again that have
happened in the president we can look at
George W Bush and the war on terror the
Pape the creation of the Patriot Act we
can look at Franklin Delano Roosevelt in
World War two with his internment of
japanese-americans we can look at World
War one with World Woodrow Wilson and
the Espionage Act and we can look of
course at Abraham Lincoln who suspended
the writ of habeas corpus and imposed
martial law and most of the North
throughout the Civil War well when we
come back to the burr conspiracy and we
think about Jefferson and his attempt to
suspend the writ of habeas corpus the
legislature literally said to Jefferson
President Jefferson I'm sorry we don't
have enough evidence of an emergency
that would warrant suspension of the
mighty writ this this jewel of Liberty
has many called it and in the midst of
the burr conspiracy one of the things
that was happening is that burr was
taking a small army and descending upon
the the Mississippi River to New Orleans
and was hoping to take over the city
well the general in command of New
Orleans at the time James Wilkinson
captured a couple of burrs
co-conspirators and rather than keeping
them in the jurisdiction in which they
were arrested which is what's supposed
to occur he threw them onboard a naval
vessel and sent them back to the East
Coast they were tried and as a result of
that trial a major Supreme Court
decision came out called ex parte Bowman
swart Wow and in the ex parte Bowman
decision the main thing that Chief
Justice's Supreme
Court John Marshall stated was that only
the legislature may suspend the writ of
habeas corpus this is the first time
that anybody had weighed in and really
discussed the writ of habeas corpus and
made a determination on who actually was
allowed to suspend it so this would mean
that a military commander can't do it it
would mean that a president can't do it
only the legislature can well
then comes the war of 1812 it begins
obviously in 1812 and it is the second
war against Great Britain I'm not going
to go into the background of why this
war occurred but many Americans at the
time called it the second war of
independence it lasted for about three
years
the Americans were hoping that they
would get a leg up on the British
because the British were involved with
Napoleon in Europe and Americans figured
well they're they're busy with with the
French and with the French allies and
maybe we can at least go and capture
Canada well that didn't happen but what
did happen is that in 1814 when the
Napoleonic Wars finally ended Napoleon
was defeated the British looked to
Americans said well now it's time to
send some real troops to America and
crush those cranky American upstarts and
they sent their best troops the
Peninsular veterans those who had
defeated Napoleon they sent them to
Washington City as it was called at the
time in August of 1814 and they burned
our Capitol to the ground they burned
every single building except for the
patent house and the only reason they
didn't burn that one is because the
patent director came running out and
said please please don't burn this
building you'll do more damage to
invention in the world than you will and
satisfying your anger towards Americans
well next came the same British force
retired to the Caribbean and planned an
assault on the southern coast New
Orleans was the perfect place to attack
it was a major port city it had because
of the war had a huge buildup of
supplies and crops cotton and other
sugar and other types of commodities in
the city and they were planning on going
and attacking this city and taking it
over General Andrew Jackson commander
the 7th Military District is
sent down to New Orleans to defend the
city he arrives there and actually even
before he arrives he receives numerous
letters from people in the city foremost
from the governor William CC Clayburn
and Claiborne says to Jackson there are
spies and traitors everywhere here no
one can be trusted and now you have to
know a little bit about the history of
New Orleans it had only become a state
in 1811 we had only purchased the
territory from France in 1803 and you've
got a really diverse culture that exists
there you have French you have English
you have Spanish you have Americans you
have this Creole culture that exists and
so Jackson is arriving there and he's
not really quite sure who to trust not
only does he receive these letters from
the governor Claiborne but he actually
finds out that a Spaniard has been
arrested on his way to Pensacola Florida
which is owned at this time by the
Spanish and he has got detailed drawings
of the defenses around New Orleans
that's a pretty good indication to a
general who's in charge of defending the
city that he's got problems well the
problems aren't only with the
possibility of traders in New Orleans he
also leads receives letters from some of
New Orleans leading citizens saying yeah
we have big problems in this city and
you know who they're coming from there
the problem of the governor so Jackson
is glad getting these conflicting
reports and he's not quite certain what
to do so he heads to New Orleans and he
tries to get a sense of what is going on
there
well then he gets news that the the
British have landed fairly close to him
on December 16th he declares martial law
in the city
it's December 16 to 1814 he's concerned
that he can't really trust anybody and
the best way to control the city to get
all of the citizens in New Orleans
Orleans on the right path and to get
them all following in the same direction
is to impose martial law this is if you
go back one slide John one more up
where's the imposition of martial law in
French in any regard
Jackson is attempting to control the
city by imposing martial law this is
only one of two images that exist of
Jackson in regard
to martial law show you another in a
moment but Jackson imposes martial law
he tries to get control of the city he
finds out that the British have actually
landed and a post rider goes out with
this news that the British have arrived
and the news gets all the way back to
Washington City and to the East Coast
and people start pulling out their maps
of New Orleans and they're looking at
where New Orleans is situated where the
river is where the lakes are where the
various bayous are and they basically
say there's no way that this city can be
defended and all of these armchair
generals are sitting around and
expecting the news of defeat at any time
if the only problem is Jackson doesn't
lose he wins the Battle of New Orleans
an amazing style
there's actually three battles that
occur the most important of which occurs
on January 8th 1815 technically this is
after the Treaty of Ghent ending the war
has already been signed in Belgium now
just because the treaty has been signed
doesn't mean that anybody in New Orleans
knows about it it also hasn't actually
been ratified by our own Senate and so
Jackson has no news of this so he's
going ahead and defending this city the
British have a sizable force far better
trained than his far better equipped
than his and far larger than his but
they make a crucial mistake in setting
up the army where they do in fact land
they've got the Mississippi River on one
side of them and a virtually
impenetrable cypress swamp on the other
side of them and the only direction they
can go is straight forward and so
Jackson sets up this amazing line be
hard behind a large mud rampart that he
sets cannons on and the the famous Jean
Lafitte the pirate he and his men man
these cannons and when the British
attack on January 8th Jackson's forces
blow the British to pieces at when the
smoke rises the battle is over after a
few hours there are 2200 British
soldiers lying dead and wounded on the
field and there are exactly 13 American
soldiers dead and wounded there has
never been a battle like this in the
history of the United States
it's the biggest victory in American
history
up to this time and when news of this
arrives to the rest of the nation
Jackson is raised to the heights of the
greatest hero the nation has ever known
next to George Washington and throughout
the rest of Jackson's career
there is often a parallel in biographies
and newspapers but directly between
Washington and Jackson many even Jack
Jackson himself mentions Washington in
regards to his own military exploits so
Jackson literally becomes an overnight
hero and the nationalism surrounding the
Battle of New Orleans is tremendous and
one of the things that I talked a good
bit about in this book is the power of
nationalism and it's something that we
all understand in our own day and we can
think about it directly after the
September 11th attacks on 9/11 is you
week all witnessed we all saw the
nationalism that existed in that in the
aftermath of those attacks with American
flags flying everywhere American flag
manufacturers couldn't keep up with the
orders that's the kind of nationalism
I'm talking about and one of the things
I say in the beginning and the
introduction of the book is that when
you think about nationalism and how it
has the power to direct the the way
people feel and especially the way the
government can act there's no question
in my mind and I haven't heard too many
historians who would dispute this that
we could not possibly have invaded Iraq
hadn't the nationalism of September 11th
not occurred well Andrew Jackson gets
himself you know he wins this great
battle and he is this national hero but
in the process of doing this he also
does some things that step on the very
Constitution he was attempting to defend
and that is his imposition of martial
law and his suspension of the writ of
habeas corpus so one of the things I
talk about in the book and this is a big
part of Jacksonian scholarship
historians have been arguing for years
whether Jackson was the great hero or
whether he was the worst despot military
tyrant military chieftain the nation has
ever known there's a real mix among
Jacksonian scholars about Jackson's
personality and what he meant to the
nation well I have argued that the seeds
of Jackson's is this duality in Jackson
come from the Battle of New Orleans he
was both a great hero
and he was a great despot as well
because when he suspends the writ of
habeas corpus and imposes martial law he
arrests quite a number of people some of
his own soldiers along with the
civilians I found a number of guard
reports from from the military records
that literally were were listed as
citizens with our prisoners with no
charges and so people were rounded up
the mayor of New Orleans at one point
since Jackson a letter saying you know
you better slow down on arresting people
because if you don't the guardhouse is
almost full and so this this creates a
problem once the battle is won this
major battle on January 8th is actually
one everybody's figures oh this is great
now Jackson's gonna lift martial law he
doesn't he is worried that this much
larger much better equipped much more
formidable British force has retreated
but they're still lying in wait
someplace and they could attack New
Orleans from another direction
this is Jackson's great concern so he
doesn't lift martial law he in fact
increases it he tightens things down
further he prepares his defenses more
he's readying himself for a battle that
never comes but of course he doesn't
know that that battle is not coming
American forces even capture a British
sailor who says oh yeah we have a whole
bunch more ships and a whole bunch more
soldiers and they're on their way and
you better get prepared so Jackson
really believes that he has a reason to
prepare well as martial law continues
not everybody is terribly happy about it
one of these people is a state senator
named Louis Lu ali-a Lou ali-a writes an
anonymous article in a local newspaper
saying you know where as we thank Andrew
Jackson for all he's done in saving this
city the time for military rule has
ended the time for the constitution to
come back and force has ended we need it
to come back in force
Jackson immediately sits down plots out
his next strategy he goes to the editor
of the newspaper and says who wrote the
article you have two choices
somebody's going to jail it can be you
or it can be the person who wrote the
article and the editor goes on there was
him it was Louis Lee oh yeah well
Jackson for
hairs he then issues an order for the
arrest of the state senator and he
issues orders that should a writ of
habeas corpus be put forward the person
issuing the writ should also be arrested
so this means that a judge is going to
be arrested somewhere down the line now
one of the things that Jackson does is
before he even actually issues the
declaration of martial law he is very
concerned about well what exactly will
martial law allow me to do and I need
some legal opinions as to whether or not
I can really do this and so he asks for
the legal opinions of two leading New
Orleans attorneys one a gentleman by the
name of Edward Livingston actually later
becomes jackson's secretary of state
when he becomes president and these
differing opinions they're very
different Edward Livingston states he
believed that it was unknown to the
Constitution or laws of the United
States and thus justified only by the
necessity of the case and that therefore
the general proclaims it at his own risk
and under his responsibility
so Livingston is saying you can do it
but it's not legal it's not
constitutional and you know whatever
happens it's on you the alternative
opinion is by another attorney Abner
dunker Duncan who insist that the
constitutional provision authorizing
suspension of the writ of habeas corpus
impliedly permitted the operation of
martial law and that was the guardian of
the public safety who is to judge of
those cases provided for by the
Constitution this is the kind of opinion
that resonates when I had earlier said
that often historical writers and
contemporary thinkers linked the
suspension of the writ of habeas corpus
directly with the issue of martial law
well as I've already said Jackson goes
ahead he imposes martial law and he
announces a definition of what he
believes martial law is and he states
martial law being established applies as
the commanding general believes to all
persons who remain within the sphere of
its operations and claims exclusive
jurisdiction of all offenses which aim
at the disorganization and ruin of the
army over which it extends to a certain
extent it is believed it makes every man
a soldier to defend the spot where
chance or choice has placed him and to
make him liable for any misconduct
calculated to
weaken its defense so Jackson's views of
Marshall are pretty clear everybody is
subject to military authority so he has
no problem whatsoever in issuing an
arrest order for a state senator a state
senator who actually had it aided in the
defense of New Orleans by remaining in
the legislature and passing defense
bills one of which was providing Jackson
with $10,000 to prepare defenses for New
Orleans but Jackson's view is he is in
complete control of the city it is his
job to maintain this city to protect
this city to make sure that the British
don't take it over hence he arrests
Louis Luoyang well next comes the writ
of habeas corpus that is put forth by
Federal District Judge ago Dominic
Augustus hall hall issues a writ of
habeas corpus and Jackson immediately
sends his soldiers to arrest Hall Hall
is thrown in exactly the same jail cell
as Lou alley a is so I suppose they can
have a nice conversation about writs of
habeas corpus and about how terrible
Andrew Jackson is Jackson then decides
he actually court-martials Lu a yay and
he Lou alia stands trial and in front of
the military commission he is exonerated
of the charges but Jackson still keeps
him in jail
Jackson decides well if I can't convict
Lou a yay I'm probably not going to be
able to convict Hall so rather than
trying to go through a trial I'm just
gonna take my soldiers send them to pick
up judge hall from the court or from the
the jail cell and escort him beyond the
city limits this is exactly what Jackson
does and he gives a letter til it to
Hall saying don't come back until you've
heard that martial law has been lifted
or that news of the Treaty of Ghent
which ends the war of 1812 has come
through well Hall doesn't have very long
to wait about two days and news of the
Treaty of Ghent comes through Jackson
immediately lifts martial law he
releases all military prisoners and
judge Hall who I have always envisioned
as marching back to New Orleans with
steam coming from his ears quickly
returns to his court contacts the state
attorney general and says excuse me the
state prosecutor and says I want an
investigation of what Jackson has done I
want an investigation of martial law I
want an investigation of his seizure
my RIT and I want to find out what's
going on here well the investigation
goes forward Jackson gets his own team
of lawyers and this goes back and forth
between the court and between Jackson's
lawyers for a little while and
ultimately Jackson is brought before the
court he arrives in the garb of a
citizen not in his military dress and
Hall says well now I am going to pose
twenty interrogatories to you
essentially legal speak for questions
and Jackson stands up and says Your
Honor I did what I did by virtue of my
military commission I was charged with
defending this city if you feel that you
need to impose some punishment have at
it
do what you must do and halt summarily
fines Jackson $1,000 for contempt of
court now this is the other scene that
is related to martial law with Jackson
it's a painting that was done in 1858 by
a Philadelphia artist named Charles
Shula often known as Christian Christian
Schuh Schley the actual painting is
located at the Gilcrease Museum in Tulsa
Oklahoma it's also the image that is on
the front cover of the book and what's
interesting about this is that this was
commissioned by a shoe merchant and
printer residing in Philadelphia who was
just very interested in this episode
there's a number of legislators who had
mentioned this scene of Jackson's
standing before the court and this is
all this is really about martial law
it's about the contempt of court fine
but what it is is Jackson is the hero if
you look at it you can see that the
judge is relegated to this kind of in
descript shadowy figure over on the side
Jackson is in the middle commanding all
of the attention the light is shining
down upon him and and what this scene
actually is is that and we don't know
for sure whether Jackson had planned on
this or whether this just occurred but
the Pirates who had aided him in
defending the city in the city the
Barrett Aryan pirates had filled the
gallery and before Jackson stood up to
you know have his sentence have the
court follow through the Pirates are all
kind of sitting in the corner going you
know
we should throw the judge in the river
and the judge actually considers
postponing the hearing and Jackson says
no no he stands up and he gets the
handout you know this is the image the
same hand that shielded this city from
harm shall shield this court in its
official duties and so it is Jackson the
hero and so but Jackson is these fined
$1,000 for contempt of court the funny
thing is you know as I said it's all
about Jackson the hero it's all about
Jackson Jacksonian nationalism and what
ends up occurring as a result of this is
Jackson leaves the city he there's a
little bit of a letter campaign that
goes back and forth between the judge
and Jackson and the various newspapers
and Jackson is intent on defending what
he has done because in the midst of all
of this the court case the immediate
aftermath of martial law he receives a
series of letters from then Secretary of
War we call the Secretary of Defense
today but then Secretary of War
Armstrong saying you know we've heard
news that you've suspended the writ of
habeas corpus and you know basically
suspended the Constitution and put
martial law in effect and you don't have
any authority to do that and we sure
hope you've listed it and so he
essentially you know through a series of
ladders Jackson essentially gets a
presidential slap on the wrist he even
says Armstrong even says that the
president is surprised and expresses
serious concerns about what is going on
in New Orleans Jackson feels like he has
to defend himself he hops on a horse
after he returns to his home of the
Hermitage in Nashville he hops on his
horse and he heads straight to
Washington City to defend his actions
and he meets with the Secretary of War
who from what we can tell what
historians can tell we only have
Jackson's description of this and one of
his friends John reader who is also his
his first biographer wrote a biography
of Jackson in 1817 and both of these men
say well the Secretary of War was
satisfied with all that Jackson had done
and had condoned his use of martial law
Madison does absolutely nothing to stem
what Jackson has done and there's a good
reason for it because Jackson was a or
excuse me a Madison was a miserable war
president he was extremely unpopular and
Jackson is the biggest hero since George
Washington President Madison does not
want to mess with Jackson at this point
he does not want to go up against the
most popular man in the nation and so he
lets the matter drop one of the things I
say in the book is that this leaves a
gaping hole in the protection of civil
liberties had Madison done something it
didn't necessarily have to be a censure
but at least had a congressional hearing
on and in a discussion about it perhaps
something else would have happened I
mean of course that's supposition on my
part because Madison does nothing well
the presidential the the the Battle of
New Orleans and the popularity the
nationalism that goes with it literally
carries Andrew Jackson to the White
House Jackson could not have become
president without the victory at the
Battle of New Orleans he is known as the
man on horseback he is recognized as the
great hero of New Orleans the Battle of
New Orleans is something that has
celebrated every single year all the way
up to the Civil War there are
celebrations big celebrations virtually
every campaign biography every newspaper
article every lithograph every image of
Jackson says something about January 8th
1815 says something about the hero of
New Orleans it's really what carries him
to the White House with this intense
popularity well nobody says anything
about martial law between the time that
Jackson imposes it and the time that he
runs for president it's only when he
runs for president that opponents start
complaining about what he had done in
New Orleans they had to however to be
very very careful because complaining
about martial law is also complaining to
some extent about the Battle of New
Orleans the greatest military victory in
the history of the country the two are
so interlinked with one another that to
criticize one is to criticize the other
and so people are fairly careful about
it well this is the the first time that
anybody has been critical of martial law
once Jackson wins the presidency the
issue of martial law pretty much goes
away there's much much bigger issues for
opponents of Jackson while he's
president he serves for two terms as
president and he
a lot of things that many people don't
like everything from attacking the Bank
of the United States and vetoing its
charter to removal of Native Americans
West to problems in what was called
nullification in a problem with the the
state of South Carolina
so there's plenty for opponents of
Jackson to argue about while he's
president it's after his presidency that
martial law again comes up and the
reason that it comes up is directly
because of Jackson he is sitting at the
hermitage in retirement he returns home
in 1837 and he's sitting back and
looking at what he sees as an otherwise
illustrious brilliant career he's won
most of his political battles he's won
virtually all of his military battles
and he sees one yet one battle that has
yet to be waged and that is the return
of his fine now prior to my working on
this book I had looked at a number of
histories very few people have discussed
martial law really at all
very few Jackson biographers have gone
in any detail on it but when they do
discuss it and they discussed the refund
of his of his fine they always linked it
to the fact that Jackson was broke he
was destitute he was in deep need of
money Jackson wasn't so much a
spendthrift but his adopted son Andrew
Jackson Jr was and he put Jackson and
real debt and so Jackson wasn't money
problem in money trouble that's not the
reason that he pushes forward with this
desire to get his fine back and in fact
Jackson you know one of the other things
that that political historians argue
about Jackson is whether or not he was a
good politician whether he was smart my
argument is that he was very smart in
regards to politics knew how to work the
political system and he slips in a
refund bill through the backdoor he
actually contacts a former a former aide
of his who served him in the Battle of
New Orleans who now is serving in the
New York legislature and sends him a
letter saying you know the only stain on
my career is this thousand-dollar
contempt fine and the only way to really
satisfy me is to have Congress refund
the fine with interest
so Jackson's got this planned out but
it's not I mean part of it is about
vanity Jackson wasn't an incredibly vain
person as so many
and formidable leaders are but it's not
just about that Jackson was absolutely
intent on setting a precedent for
emergency powers in the United States he
wanted to absolutely make sure that
other generals faced with the same
situation that he was faced in with
would not be curtailed by the
Constitution that they would be able to
do what was necessary at that immediate
moment to safeguard the nation and he
says the you know the Congressional
refund debates run from 1842 to 1844 and
one of the things Jackson says is I
asked what general hereafter if New
Orleans was again threatened with
invasion let the real necessity be what
it might and the most energetic measures
for its defense necessary would hazard
the responsibility of adopting those
energetic measures by which the country
could alone be defended while the record
of the fine and loss stared him in the
face inflicted upon me by an unjust
judge for declaring Martial Law
well legislators in Congress discuss
this both houses of Congress wrangle
over this issue of refunding Jackson's
fine and there are a lot of Ardea
ideological issues that are thrown about
a lot of constitutional issues that are
thrown about the fact is whether you
like what Jackson did in New Orleans or
not he defied the Constitution he
violated the Constitution he had no
authority to suspend the writ of habeas
corpus he had no authority to impose
martial law he had more than that he
arrests the State Senator arrests a
judge these caused problems for some
people the other problem that is going
on in the 1840s is that this is after
Jackson has served two terms as
president of the United States the
second American party system is made up
of the Democrats and the Whig party the
Whigs are founded specifically in
opposition to Andrew Jackson they hate
him and I mean hate him it's one of the
funniest things today is that I'll often
hear political pundits or newspaper
writers talk today or or columnist say
oh you know the partisanship today is
just terrible I wish we could look back
to those good old days when you know
people just got along better they don't
know history
the Democrats and the Whigs absolutely
could not stand one another they they
referred to Jackson as King Andrew the
first meaning that he was so powerful
and so dangerous to the Republic that he
was the greatest threat to a
constitutional republic well into this
kind of an atmosphere when a bill to
refund Jackson fine arrives the Whigs
look at it and go why would we want to
do something for Jackson we hate him
well the other problem is that in 1840
the Whigs win their very first
presidential election prior to this the
Democrats had always been in control not
only of Congress but of the presidency
as well now the Whigs I should say they
win the presidential election of 1840 it
doesn't really work out too nicely for
them though because their candidate
William Henry Harrison is the first
president to ever die in office he dies
one month after his inauguration he had
walked around Washington in a kind of
drizzling cold rainy March day
inauguration day at this time was on
March 4th and he gets a cold contracts
pneumonia and he's dead within a month
his vice president John Tyler had only
become a Whig he was actually really a
Democrat and so the Whigs are you know
screaming we won the presidency we lost
the presidency but the problem for the
Democratic Party is that they have
really been reeling since Jackson's
retirement he was the the unifying
political symbol for the Democratic
Party and so when he retires the
Democrats lose this real unifier the
symbol of the party and when the Whigs
hear about this refund bill they say you
know what this isn't about doing
something for Jackson this is just a
democratic campaign ploy to bring
Jackson's name before the people in
anticipation of the off-year
congressional elections in 1843
and in anticipation of the 1844
presidential election this is just a
campaign ploy and we're not going to let
them have it now this doesn't have not
been the Democratic impetus but once the
Whigs start yelling about this the
Democrats go that's a good idea
and I actually have a couple of
different letters from Francis Preston
Blair who is the editor of the
washington-based globe the Democratic
newspaper in Washington City and a very
very good friend of Jackson's and he
actually says in a series of letters
after the debates go on for a while he
says you know it would be better if this
bill didn't pass right away because this
is great we're using it to affect in the
congressional elections we're gonna use
it for the presidential election we
don't want the Whigs to have the credit
of passing this bill for you so let's
string it out for a while
and Jackson is thrilled to hear this
that not only will his well he get to
have this stain removed from his record
and not only will he get to set a
precedent for emergency powers but he'll
get to help his party as well so the
partisanship that is involved in this
bill is overwhelming and it naturally
affects the ideological arguments that
are going on this is not some kind of
debate that occurs where they have a
serious ideological debate of conviction
about when emergency powers are
necessary and if the nature in the
nation is in danger should we suspend
the Constitution that's not really what
this debate is about this debate is all
about
partisan strategizing it's all about
electoral advantage so the larger idea
the ideological issues are subsumed by
this bigger partisan agenda and in the
end run Jackson does in fact get his
money back they the the the Democrats
take control of both the House and the
Senate in the off year elections and in
1844 the House passes a a bill to refund
Jackson's fine On January 8th 1844 the
anniversary of the Battle of New Orleans
they want to have as much symbolic
effect as they possibly can and then
just a few you know a little less than a
month later they are a little more than
a month later excuse me the Senate
follows suit well the problem is is that
this refund bill that is past returns
Jackson's fine plus interest he gets
around $2,700 I guess it's forced
savings it doesn't say a word not one
word about the legality of what Jackson
has done it doesn't say a word about the
legality or illegality of martial law
about his suspension of habeas corpus
nothing
and so one could say well what-what does
the bill mean then does the Democratic
view of suspending the writ of habeas
corpus and imposing martial law entail
or does the Whig view of not doing it
entail well I think the common sense
would say the damage action one the
Democrats won they passed the bill
therefore the Democratic view wins well
this is certainly how the various
military and legal treatises treat the
issue one of the things I did for the
book is I looked at every single
military and legal treatise every single
legal dictionary every single court
hearing and court decision in regards to
defining martial law I looked at all of
them prior to the 18 42 to 44 debates
every one of them to in addition defined
martial law as military law martial law
was essentially synonymous with military
law military laws we understand it today
is a code of conduct for the Armed
Forces so it is applicable only to
people who are serving in the military
martial law has something more
extraordinary something that can be
imposed upon civilians is entirely
different
in every single judicial decision every
single military and legal treatise if it
mentioned that kind of martial law it
said it's absolutely an asthma to our
Constitution it couldn't exist in this
land of Liberty it's illegal well when I
started looking at these military and
legal treaties these court decisions in
the aftermath of the refun debates you
slowly over about a ten-year period
start seeing a new definition of martial
law creep in and now they start talking
about not only is there this thing such
as military law that's for them for the
Armed Forces but there's also something
known as martial law that's this more
extraordinary power that can be imposed
upon civilians so the refund debates
have a significant effect on the
definition and on the precedent of
martial law becoming something more than
than illegal illegal and annan atma to
the American Constitution and the
important issue that that arises is that
is there going to be another time in US
history
when Marshall law becomes necessary
again when it is required again where
our leader believes that it's time to
suspend the writ of habeas corpus again
well the next time that this comes is of
course the Civil War when the Civil War
begins
President Abraham Lincoln as he starts
to prepare the military to defend the
nation and defend the nation's capital
he hears of Confederate armies being
formed he is trying to prepare the
nation's defense and one of the things
he does is he issues an order on April
27th 1861 to his commanders suspending
the writ of habeas corpus now according
to ex parte Bowman Swart Wow from 1807
only the president could suspend the
writ of habeas corpus but Jackson did it
right
Lincoln believes that he can do it and
he in fact does do it he suspends the
writ of habeas corpus and the first case
that comes about in regards to the writ
of habeas corpus is the arrest of a man
named John Merriman in Maryland Merriman
is a southern sympathizer he is arrested
for burning railroad bridges in Maryland
and for preparing troops to go down into
the south and and serve with the
Confederacy he is arrested by military
authorities in Maryland and he has
whisked off to a military prison a writ
of habeas corpus is requested by then
Supreme Court Justice Roger Brooke tani
tani issues the writ of habeas corpus to
the general and in charge of the of the
military prison a general Cadwallader
and Cadwallader sends a note back to the
Chief Justice a respectful note stating
you know dear Chief Justice tani I
cannot honor your writ of habeas corpus
and he sends him a copy of Lincoln's
April 20th 27th order suspending the
writ of habeas corpus well what happens
is that tani sits down and writes
furiously a response to Lincoln's
suspension of the writ this is one of in
terms of constitutional terms this is
one of the most famous court decrees in
regards to defending Liberty that there
is it is called X
arte Merriman and I want to read you a
fairly long quote but I think that it's
important to give you the thrust of what
Tony's thinking on this was Tony States
a military officer has no right to
arrest and detain a person not subject
to the rules and Articles of War for an
offense against the laws of the United
States except an aide of judicial
authority and subject to its control and
if the party be arrested by the military
it is the duty of the officer to deliver
him over immediately to the civil
authority to be dealt with according to
law the military in this case has gone
far beyond the mere suspension of the
privilege of the writ of habeas corpus
it has by force of arms thrust aside the
judicial authorities and officers to
whom the Constitution has confided the
power and duty of interpreting and
administering the laws and substituted a
military government in its place I can
only say that if the authority which the
Constitution has confided to the
judiciary Department and judicial
officers may thus upon any pretext or
under any circumstances be usurped by
the military power at its discretion the
people of the United States are no
longer living under a government of laws
but every citizen holds life liberty and
property at the will and pleasure of the
army officer in whose military district
he may happen to be found now this is a
ringing defense of Liberty Lincoln who
is in the midst of this rebellion
essentially ignores Tony's statement but
constitutional historians and legal
scholars have looked at the ex parte
Merryman as a major as I've already said
as a major decree on the sanctity of
Liberty in the United States and I just
want to read excuse me what a couple of
constitutional scholars have said in
1936 Charles W Smith lauded Tawny's
quote almost religious zeal for
individual rights
noting believing as he did in a
government of law Tony looked with
abhorrence on anything that saver of
military rule
Carl Swisher in 1974 wrote a history of
the Supreme Court of the United States
that extended over a number of different
justices but in his volume on Tony
he specifically safe stated the Merryman
decision quote rings clear for all who
fear unnecessary expansion of executive
power on the part of various military
leaders so on at face value
one would think Thani is this great
defender of Liberty he is going up
against Lincoln under no circumstances
should the military control what is
going on and it writ sedition writs of
habeas corpus should always be honored
the president doesn't have the authority
to suspend it well this isn't the whole
story when it comes to Tony Tony had
gained the Chief Justice of the Supreme
Court position as a result of Andrew
Jackson
Tony had served as Jackson's Attorney
General and as Jackson's secretary of
the Treasury and as a reward for doing
well for Jackson Jackson appoints tani
as Chief Justice of Supreme Court upon
John Marshall's death and in the midst
of the refun debates in the 1840s tani
has a decidedly different opinion about
military rule and writs of habeas corpus
than he expresses in the in the Merriman
decision and one of the interesting
things for me when I was working on this
book it was originally my did my
doctoral dissertation is and I wrote the
dissertation under Marquis Neely jr. who
won the 1992 Pulitzer Prize winner in
history for a book on Lincoln and and
civil liberties and I found these two
letters that I'm gonna read to you in a
second on taani and I brought them to
Professor Neely's office and I said you
know professor Neely have you seen these
letters by tawny you know in his
opinions on on civil liberty and writs
of habeas corpus and and I remember mark
well looking at the letters wide-eyed
and saying I wish I had those letters
when I wrote the fate of Liberty
so to his understanding no
constitutional scholars had seen these
letters and they should because they're
remarkable now you remember what I just
quoted in regards to tani on in his ex
parte Merriman decision here's what he
says to Jackson in the spring of 1843
when he's responding to Whigs passing
amendments to the Jackson refund bill
tani writes Jackson this treason within
New Orleans was prevented from show
itself only by the vigor of your
measures and the splendor of your
victory he writes subsequently after the
fine Pat after the fine bill passes
future ages will be amazed that such
conduct as that of judge Hall could find
defenders or apologists in this country
and how there could be any difficulty in
stigma sought stigmatizing the
disgraceful proceeding in the manner it
deserves Tony our judge Hall's conduct
was as unjust and in my judgment a
grosser act of injustice was never
perpetrated by any court than the
infliction of that fine upon you well
that creates some problems for the
Merryman decision well in terms of
Jackson and martial law Abraham Lincoln
he suspends the writ of habeas corpus
it's a couple of years later when the
Congress ultimately goes ahead and
actually officially suspends the writ of
habeas corpus I mean Lincoln has already
done it and it has followed through and
he's been able to enforce it but
Congress does back him up in 1863 he
still however is getting a lot of grief
from those who are opposing him and the
people who were opposing Lincoln and his
actions during the Civil War are
Democrats the Whig party has essentially
disintegrated in the 1850s and out of it
not solely you know the Whigs don't
become the Republican Party of Abraham
Lincoln but there are many Whigs who
become Republicans Abraham Lincoln is
one of them he had been a Whig
he becomes a Republican the Democrats
are now the loyal opposition in regards
to the Civil War and they are not
pleased in the least about Lincoln
suspension of habeas corpus about his
declaration and military of martial law
about his use of the military to control
civilians well Lincoln is very pleased
to let them know that Andrew Jackson was
the great defender of the Union and that
he in fact had suspended the writ of
habeas corpus and had imposed martial
law and in response to what has become
known as the Corning letter a gentleman
named Erastus Corning from New York
wrote to wrote to Lincoln complaining of
his violation of the Constitution and
Lincoln responds and in what is known as
the Corning letter he says after the
Battle of New Orleans
while the fact that the Treaty of Peace
had been concluded was well known in the
city but before initial knowledge of it
had arrived General Jackson still
maintained Marshall or military law it
may be remarked first that we had the
same Constitution then as now secondly
that we then had a case of invasion and
now have a case of rebellion and thirdly
that the permanent rights of the people
to public discussion the Liberty of
speech and of the press the trial by
jury the law of evidence and the law and
the habeas corpus suffered no detriment
whatever by the conduct of general
Jackson or its subsequent approval by
the American Congress subsequent
approval by American the American
Congress now if you remember I explained
that the bill were funding Jackson's
fine didn't say a word about the
legality of what Jackson had done it had
left it alone but the legal and military
treatises that follow the debates bring
about this new definition of martial law
and Lincoln certainly knew what his own
party had argued about during the refun
debates that Whigs had been virtually
completely against Jackson's use of
martial law and that the Democrats are
the ones who had championed martial law
well you get to the 1860s and the sides
have reversed themselves completely the
Democrats that you know I find a number
of Democrats who had actually served in
the Congress and and been involved in
the debates in the 1840s who are still
around in the 1860s and I show in the
book in the last chapter how they just
fundamentally reversed their opinions on
martial law whereas they had supported
in the 1840s they no longer supported in
the 1860s
I find Whigs who in the 1840s had been
against martial law and in the 1860s
they're suddenly in favor of martial law
and when you read these debates about
these debates there are a number of
national legislative celebrities that
that come across the stage on this you
have a president you know future
President James Buchanan
you've got the future vice president of
the Confederacy
Stephens thick Alexander Stephens thank
you you've got as I said James Buchanan
you've got Stephen Douglas is involved
in these you've got and most of them are
giving their maiden speeches in the
Congress in relation to the refund bill
so these are people who are involved in
this matter who later become big players
and one of them one of the really
remarkable ones is a guy by the name of
skank
who is from Ohio and he delivers the
last speech in 1844 on the refund debate
and he says you know the Democrats have
been talking about necessity that you
know when necessity comes and there's an
emergency that necessity trumps all else
and skank stands up and says necessity
is the plea of tyrants Jackson is a
tyrant he shouldn't have done what he
did and he gives this fiery speech in
opposition to passing the refund bill
well guess what skank can't be comes in
1860s general skank and he subsequently
declares martial law and I actually said
it set his speeches defending his
declaration of martial law directly next
to Jackson's and they're almost
identical and I also show his speech in
relation to a number of different
Democratic speeches and they're
virtually identical and so the positions
have just absolutely flip-flopped and
one of the things I've been interested
in then with this book and I'm not sure
whether I'm successful in getting at it
or not I suppose that reviewers in the
future will make that determination is
I'm very interested in the the
confluence between ideology and
partisanship where does partisanship
strategizing the desire for to maintain
to gain and maintain party power where
does that jibe with ideological
conviction it's a difficult thing to get
at and I would guess that if you ask
most voters on the most citizens and
voters on the street today
there'd be fairly jaded and they go out
ideology but there is ideology out there
and there's also partisan tactics out
there and it all exists within these
debates and one of the things to me that
is remarkable about this this you know
amazingly important constitutional issue
is that you can have these politicians
in a 20-year period flip-flop 180
degrees no consistency whatsoever and
when I when I started reading various
treaties in the 1860s about Lincoln and
his use of martial law and when Lincoln
up holds Jackson as as an example of you
know look Jackson did it he was your
leader now can't I do it as well the
Democrats run long and hard from this
precedent that their own party had
created and I found a number of
different treatises where Democratic
writers are are actually saying well
that's not really what the Democrats net
in the 1840s and then they actually
quote Whig speeches from the refun
debates so I mean if the flip-flop
couldn't be more complete than that I
don't know how it can't be more complete
than that so to me when you're talking
about one of the most fundamental issues
in the United States the issue of
Liberty and you know we've heard George
Bush speak on numerous occasions that
we're fighting the Iraqi war for liberty
that this nation stands for Liberty that
and and really if you look throughout
American history freedom and liberty is
one of the cornerstones of the things
that we focus upon that we rely upon
that we discuss and in my mind to be
able to have a debate about this where
it's really all about partisan
strategizing and then they can just
completely reverse their positions later
it's troubling and it's problematic and
now we are faced today with these issues
again and can we look to the Past with
issues of martial law with precedents in
relation to Marshall
with suspensions of writs of habeas
corpus can we look to these things in
the past to give us some guidance today
and you know I started this talk with a
variety of things that have occurred
just in the last five weeks in relation
to the right of habeas corpus in
relation to martial law and the the
sanctity of the Constitution and I guess
my common sense would tell me that in
times of serious emergency I mean if
you're gonna really truly be objective
about it not be partisan not look at it
through democratic eyes or not look at
it through Republican eyes if you're
gonna be objective about it there are
certainly times when emergencies arise
when the Constitution may not be up to
the task of safeguarding citizens I mean
if you have an invasion force do you
really want a judge hampering the
military who is defending being against
the invasion having to deal with the
judge of a writ of habeas corpus in the
midst of an invasion I would say the
common sense should tell you know that
that's not right we don't want that to
happen the problem that arises now and
that is different for us today than it
has ever been in the past is the
question of duration all of the
suspensions of the writ of habeas corpus
and the imposition of martial law in the
past have been relatively short and
duration Jackson never believed that he
was going to hold martial law in place
forever
and in fact at the end of the whole
trial and everything I mean even before
the trial when judge Hall finds him the
thousand dollars I mean Jackson was in
charge of the military there he could
have got the order from judge Hall to be
summoned before the court Jackson could
have just went forget you I'm not
showing up I'm not going to the court
try and pull me in I've got all my
military here Jackson didn't have to go
into the courtroom that day but he
understood that he needed to relinquish
military military control that that what
is written within many con state
constitutions during this time period is
that the military shall always remain
subordinate to civil authority we don't
want a military dictatorship in this
country so Jackson never believed that
martial law was going to live forever
Lincoln certainly didn't believe that
the Civil War was going to go on forever
Roosevelt when he interned
Japanese didn't believe that World War
two was gonna go on forever the problem
that we face today in regards to the war
on terror is that it's not a traditional
enemy we're not fighting a nation-state
we are fighting an insurgency that
doesn't have defined geographical
borders how long will this go on how
long should we allow suspensions of the
writ of habeas corpus which are in
effect now not for all of you unless you
take alberto gonzalez's opinion I mean
if you're gonna look at the Attorney
General's view of that no citizen of the
United States that no person in the
United States has the right of habeas
corpus any single one oath is any person
in this room if you speak out against
the government you could be arrested and
thrown in jail indefinitely
no writ of habeas corpus for you um
that's a scary thought and I'm not
trying right now to make a political
statement about George Bush or the war
on terror I'm talking about a kind of
wider ideological idea about the concept
of liberty and about the concept of the
Constitution and the concept of habeas
corpus I do believe that these things
need to be defended and so what we're
talking about today are our duration and
if we're going to allow these kinds of
infringement on the Constitution these
kinds of violations for an indefinite
period of time with no end in sight what
is that going to do to our Republic what
is that going to do to the rule of law
thank you
now thank you very much now if anybody
would like to ask me some questions
there's a microphone up there bring the
microphone to the center would you would
you come up and ask the question at the
microphone so that they can record it
please I heard in the radio of just this
afternoon that the Canadian Supreme
Court has ruled that people cannot be
held indefinitely simply on charges of
terrorism and I was wondering what you
might want to comment on that if you if
you see a relevancy they're sure there's
absolutely a relevancy I mean it plays
directly into the issues that we're
facing today and you know what one of
the things you'll find is that when if
you discuss these contemporary issues
especially about issues regarding
Guantanamo Bay where enemy combatants
have been held indefinitely for a number
of years and you you'll talk to somebody
who wants to be a defender of the
president administrator of the present
administration and they'll say well but
do you want terrorists terrorists you
know roaming around aren't they gonna
hurt the nation well no of course you
don't want terrorists rolling around
roaming around but we are a nation built
on laws and on the precedent of law and
you should at least give these people a
day in court to determine whether they
are in fact terrorists that's the
problem and and this has been something
that's been going on with a number of
the lawyers who have been defending pro
bono for free these these prisoners held
in in Guantanamo Bay and they've been
saying exactly the same thing that you
know rule of law if you're not going to
follow through on the Constitution and
make sure that the law is applicable to
everyone at what point will the law no
longer be applicable to you that's what
we must defend against so you know I see
the Canadian decision that I haven't I
did not hear that but I see that pretty
consistent with the issues that are
going on today of course
I think is excellent but specifically to
Guantanamo Bay you also have the issue
of location and I think it's a great
parallel that you brought up where's
Jackson escorted someone out of a
military zone at Guantanamo Guantanamo
excuse me they're escorting them into
that zone I'm wondering if you could
speak a little bit about that well you
know I don't know that they're exactly
synonymous because with what Jackson has
he has a theater of operations that are
going on I mean it is a direct military
zone with Guantanamo you're talking
about a specific military base but where
American soil exists so goes the flag so
goes the Constitution that's the issue
and that's the idea in regards to the
rule of law so if you are going to bring
people onto American soil then the
Constitution applies there and this is
one of the things that was discussed in
the Honda versus Rumsfeld decision and
you know there are other things that we
could talk about in regards to that I
mean one of the things that the Bush
administration has done is set up these
these secret CIA prisons in other
countries so that in terms of
interrogation techniques they don't have
to worry about what American
representatives are doing in that regard
so IIIi think that answers the question
but you know I mean one of the other
things that is at play here which I
neglected to mention which I also think
is important is the question of trust in
government if you know and I've asked
this question of my students many times
you know are you guys willing to give up
some of your rights in order to
safeguard the nation and many students
are already that yeah of course I'll do
that not a problem I want to safeguard
this nation so I'll give up some of my
rights and the issue with that is do you
trust your government do you have faith
in the government if you trust the
government and you have faith in the
government you are more willing to give
them a certain degree of leeway and
there are plenty of people who don't
trust this particular government and I
mean this is also one of the problems
that exist for Jackson it was one of the
problems that existed for a Lincoln as
well the opponents of these two men
didn't trust them
and therefore any power at their hands
could be potentially very dangerous and
this is the way many opponents of the
Bush administration feel today two
questions for you Matt first off in
terms of the switch in the position of
the parties I wonder if that may have
started earlier in the Mexican War after
all the martial law was opposed in the
Mexican area under Democratic President
James Cape Hulk with two Whig general
Zachary Taylor and with God and as I
understand it martial law was declared
and sort of neither party
you know objected to it that's one
question and the second question is in
terms of defining martial law I think
you've made an excellent case that it's
largely a creature of politics and I'm
wondering therefore it isn't there a
great deal difference between Lincoln's
suspension of habeas corpus and what
we've seen back in the original Jackson
situation in that there was virtually no
opposition of Jackson back in 1815
whereas during Lincoln's era of course
you have a large you know Democratic
constituency in North which it could did
complain about his actions and a wonder
if that somewhat trimmed Lincoln's sales
more than Jackson's were trimmed back to
me back in 1815 first in regards to
Winfield Scott I actually had this
conversation with a with a Scott
historian a couple of years ago and he
was asking me specifically what do you
think about Winfield Scott's declaration
of martial law in the Mexican War and I
said well it wasn't really martial law
he was an invading military force that
took control of civilians and took
control of the military occupied area
that to me is not the same as martial
law so there's a distinct difference
between what Winfield Scott did and what
Andrew Jackson and and what Abraham
Lincoln did martial law and my view is
when you are placing the military in
control of your own citizens within your
own nation and when you have an invading
army that's going into another area
that's that's not
the same thing as martial law at least
not in the context of the way that I've
been describing it so that I think that
addresses the Winfield Scott question in
regards to the differences between
Lincoln and Jackson yes there are
definitely differences primarily in
terms of scope Jackson doesn't in a very
limited area at the time nobody really
argues with him really nobody in quite
knows what's going on in New Orleans I
mean as I said when the news of the
British arrival just below and nor New
Orleans arrives in Washington everybody
figures that the battle has been lost
they only start finding out about
martial law towards the tail end of it
and sure is there a possibility that
somebody might have said something about
it
yeah if Jackson had lost but he wins and
as I said he's this gigantic national
hero and I think that Madison should
have said something about it I think he
should have brought it before the
Congress and said you know what I don't
think Jackson men ill-will but this is
unconstitutional and this is something
that our Congress should discuss we're a
nation built on Liberty and built on a
Constitution a republic based on law and
we should have a conversation about
whether this is okay or not and they
don't do that and I would say that the
reason that Jackson gets no opposition
is specifically because of the
nationalism of the battle it's such a
huge battle the war of 1812 had gone so
incredibly poorly as I said Washington
city was burned you know the president
is on his way out to the battlefield to
supervise the defenses and he's got
soldiers running past him and he's going
like this and then he realizes uh the
British are about to take over the city
and he literally escapes into the
countryside barely for Lincoln it's a
much wider scale issue there's already
tremendous political partisan opposition
that has been building for years prior
to the Civil War so there's no
preparation for what Jackson does for
what happens with Lincoln the issue is
much more contested the
you've already got a lot of political
animosity that is moving towards the
1860s 1860 1861 I mean the the
sectionalism that allows the civil war
to erupt you know it had existed mean
sexual historians does have debated and
argued about this for a long time in my
view the sectionalism really explodes
when we annex Texas and we get involved
in the Mexican War and you have you're
dealing with the issue of the expansion
of slavery westward and that creates a
lot of not only sectional animosity but
political animosity as well mean when
you go into the election of 1860 the the
only reason that Lincoln wins that
election is because the Democratic Party
has split they have they've proposed a
northern candidate Stephen Douglas and a
southern candidate John Breckinridge if
you tally the votes for those two men
they win more votes than Lincoln does
popular votes but because they've split
it between two different candidates they
lose the election so that that
partisanship that occurs over Lincoln's
decision has already existed it isn't
building and the the nation is virtually
at fever pitch if there had been no
opposition to what Lincoln had done it
that that would have been remarkable not
the fact that there is opposition
Matt in your opinion has anything really
changed from from the 1800's to modern
time now or do the people in Washington
and and power just tweak it to suit
their needs
well you want my optimistic answer or my
pessimistic answer what do you think you
know it's a real problem there's a lot
of people who say there's no difference
between the two political parties I
think that that is very mistake and I
think there's a huge difference between
the two political parties but the major
problem between these two political
parties and the thing that they do have
in common and the reason why people
think there's no difference is because
of the way they operate and the amount
of power that they actually have they
are machines and they've been machines
since the 1830s 1840s they are expert at
electioneering they are expert at
raising money they are expert at
controlling the dialogue in Washington
no third party movement in the United
States has ever been successful those
that are successful ideologically in
pushing an idea usually get their idea
stolen by the two major parties the two
parties just incorporate that idea
within their own parties and they run
with it and so I mean that's one of the
real problems in Washington today is
that the parties are as much about
pushing a particular agenda as they are
about gaining and maintaining their own
party power this is one of the reasons
why we can't get good campaign reform in
Washington because it's like asking the
rats to guard the cheese you can't get
it done and this is I think one of the
things that frustrates Americans so much
and you can see some examples of people
trying to step out of that I mean I
don't agree with everything that Ralph
Nader says but I do think that Ralph
Nader is a tremendously ideologically
driven person and one of those you know
he got a lot of flack for not stepping
out of the presidential race in the year
2000 and
i from an ideological point of view i
understand why he couldn't do it because
he was so sick of the standard operating
procedure between the Democratic Party
and the Republican Party that he just
couldn't come to the point where he said
all right well I'll step out so Al Gore
can win he just couldn't do it because
he was so tired of exactly the thing
that many Americans are tired with and
that is this constant politicking this
constant partisanship I mean look we all
know when we watch what goes on in the
press that that many of our senators and
congressmen are engaged more in
politicking and power grabbing and
making sure that their party is is
stable and in power and can get that
opportunity to gain power then they are
about pushing a particular agenda or
what is best for America I mean I saw Al
Gore not long ago giving interview in
which he said you know at this point I
wish that George Bush would make a
decision about the Iraq war based more
on what is good for America as a nation
then he would about his legacy and his
party and I thought at the time that it
was a good point it's a fundamental
problem and is there a difference
between today and you know 150 years ago
unfortunately no I mean that may be one
of the lessons in this book if there are
any lessons that partisanship even when
you're discussing something as important
as the idea of Liberty as the nature of
the Constitution the right of habeas
corpus that even when you're discussing
something that's that this critical to
the United States that legislators still
engage in politicking with it and I find
now I show a variety of different
examples in the book of this you know
and one of the the most amazing was John
Quincy Adams in the 1840s Adams delivers
two different speeches two months apart
in one of the speeches he just
absolutely attempts to destroy Jackson
for utilizing martial law and in the
speech two months earlier on a different
subject
he had lauded martial law and said that
well this is great martial law is a good
thing because if Mark
law goes into effect well military
commanders can emancipate slaves so for
one thing that Adams liked martial law
was good for him for something else that
he didn't like martial law was no good
and that kind of politicking that causes
of otres in this country to go you
scratch their heads and go he does it
matter should I vote why should I even
bother and that's I mean really one of
the big problems facing America today
you know you look at national elections
we have fifty percent voter turnout it's
the lowest of any industrialized country
in the world that's not a good thing
when you did your research and
originally you you brought up the fact
that Jackson approached a newspaper to
find out who wrote that article and if
you could comment a little bit about how
the media operated then as opposed to
how the media has been operating
currently under Bush's reign how is the
media have been ahead of the curve in in
getting the word out on the protection
of American rights where have they been
kind of playing the politic game and
sitting back versus being proactive
what's what's your thought on what you
saw in the past and what you see
currently well in terms of the past in
regards to to the media I mean it's it's
all newspapers and when you look at
newspapers from these time periods there
are very few of any independent
newspapers at this time they're all
partisan they belong to one party or
they belong to the other party and in
fact quite often you have newspapers
that are created in particular cities
specifically by a certain political
party so that they can have a voice in
that city to balance against the
opposition newspaper that's very very
common I've done a lot of research on
how Jackson's death was treated when he
died in 1845 and I got to the point you
know I wrote one article on how New York
City responded to his death they had a
commemoration with 40,000 people who
marched in in the the commemoration they
put the thing together in six days and
one of the things I tried to juxtapose I
called Macy's to their marketing
department I said could you tell me how
many people marched in your last Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade and how long you
put it together and the woman very
proudly said we had 12,000 people we
spent eight months and I said Jackson
40,000 people six days boy could
politics be important at this time and
you also have to remember that at this
time you've got 80 percent voter turnout
during this time politics during this
period is a sport it's an entertainment
everybody gets involved in it of course
we don't have cable television we don't
have movies we don't have you know
professional sports so that that's an
aspect of it but all newspapers at this
time are partisan when I was doing the
research on Jackson's death I could
literally pick up a newspaper read a few
paragraphs and I would know which party
that the newspaper it belonged to so I
mean that's the idea of press during
this time for contemporary times for
what we're dealing with today in regards
to what Alberto Gonzalez said about the
right of habeas corpus you know how much
I've seen written on it zero nothing hey
I saw it from a legislative release not
from the media
the only thing about martial law that I
saw is the the February 19th New York
Times article I haven't seen any major
media outlet pick up on these issues I
think that this is one of the reasons
that my book is resonating a little bit
because people are interested in these
ideas and martial law and issues of
habeas corpus but no I think the media
the media today has fallen flat on these
issues they have not addressed them
enough and you know whether or not the
the media today is particularly partisan
in one one direction or another you know
I talked to conservative friends who say
all that media it's all liberal and I
talk to liberal friends who say all that
media it's all conservative and so you
know it depends on which side of the the
argument you're at but for the most part
there's a lot that the media today has
not done well and this you know this
again brings up all kinds of other
issues of how big media conglomerates
should allowed to be should you know
should the FCC have stronger
restrictions on who can own how many
radio stations how many television
stations how many newspapers
to determine you know I still think one
of the best sources of really good
reporting is the BBC and look at the BBC
online you'll you'll get a lot of
answers that you don't see in in America
media I answer any other questions all
right
well again thank you
okay thank you thank you again let let
me just say one more time thank you very
very much for coming it's nice to see a
lot of friendly faces who I know I would
also like to really thank my colleague
John Tully who helped me put together
the PowerPoint and helped to run it for
me today he was a big help with this and
I would also like to thank my US
sectionalism class that let me do a dry
run of this talk on Thursday and pointed
out all of the mistakes that I made so
thank you very much